let's get to less political and more
apocalyptic
yeah here we go here we go this one's
good we got to play this clip this is uh
so disclose that tv tweeted new new york
city emergency management shared a video
today outlining the important steps for
new yorkers to follow if a nuclear
attack occurs
and my first question is why
and uh they've created a modernized let
me let me play this video for you
so there's been a nuclear attack don't
ask me how or why just know that the big
one has hit okay so
what do we do
there are three important steps that i
want you to remember step one
get inside fast you your friends your
family get inside and no staying in the
car is not an option you need to get
into a building and move away from the
windows
[Applause]
step two
stay inside
shut all doors and windows until the
middle of the step three keep
radioaction
follow media for more information
don't forget to sign up for notifynyc
for official alerts and updates
and don't go outside until officials say
it's safe
all right
you've got this
like i i couldn't help but notice that
it's another emergency preparedness
thing about not leaving your home you
know we had like cove don't go outside
yeah now it's like nuclear text don't go
outside well first of all
tim and i were watching this before we
went on air no new york city apartment
looks like that right when she was like
get into your basement i was like what
are you a billionaire a basement my
bedroom was my bathroom she means your
basement apartment that costs you 800
bucks
and it's like a single cement cube
yeah also get inside are you sure
in a lot of those rickety old buildings
oh right that's right after an attack
that's not really good well i mean well
but they said
they go get inside and stay away from
windows
get inside and make sure you get right
to the windows that was the second step
it's like which one you want me to do
should i get to the windows yeah the
first one was get in and get away from
the windows and step number two shut
doors you're right the doors and windows
shut them yeah so what do you want me to
do wow
i can't shut them i'm too far away which
one do i say i thought you wanted to get
away from the windows and now you tell
me to go at him i'm already confused and
this is just the first instruction
i also her jovial tone was a little um
a jarring when she's like so there's
been an attack and just kind of like
sexily walked onto the screen and when
she tried to make the joke like no silly
a car isn't inside you're about to burn
to death it was very bad and by inside
we mean you'll be under a ton of bricks
on fire and the survivors will be having
three-headed dead babies for the next 10
years when you get up to heaven what is
happening my first question for the
panel is what are you talking about why
are they putting out a how to survive a
nuclear strike video uh tim did you not
listen to the beginning when she said
don't ask why yeah it doesn't matter how
it doesn't matter how or why i guessed
me yes it does new york lady it
definitely matters i think russia
obviously
i think
it feels cold warish doesn't it cold
watch can i can i just i pulled up the
nuke map i love this website i guess
where hot water you pick a city yeah and
then you can pick the weapon so i've
i've chosen the largest icbm which is
the titan ii warhead nice it's a nine
megaton bomb there is literally nowhere
in new york you will survive yeah new
york city that is new york city right
nice um well look
uh i guess
where's queen ends where does where does
queens end
queen ends
i'm pretty sure flushing
flushing
and jamaica but good name is that still
new york city flushing is where are you
squeezing some okay so you are you are
in the
thermal radiation radius and will suffer
third degree burns i suppose you would
want to be inside but i'd imagine
i don't know where you're in new york
and you'll see an icbm coming and be
like well i better go inside better look
at the basement
if you are in
like so look at this like new jersey
hoboken by even newark you're in the
blast damage area
let me be fair newark has been in the
blast lightning blast damage
yeah they do already look like this has
happened
oh that's the yeah thermal okay so the
fireball radius takes out the financial
district up to um
around midtown union square and flatiron
gets wiped out in a fireball then
everything around
around here
up to the bronx
all of the jersey coast
and up to queens and flushing brooklyn's
gone except for like coney island i'm
excited for brooklyn to be like how do
we gentrify rubble
yeah but that's that's the moderate
blast damage coffee shop
most residential buildings collapse
injuries are universal fatalities are
widespread most buildings collapse but
they're telling people to get in their
buildings yep i mean where else we're
going to hide i guess it would be so
funny if just trump tower survived
it would have been funny
if in this video she says
if you're in the areas of the bronx
flushing jamaica coney island get into
your building everyone else
see you later yeah yeah if you're seeing
if you're rich get into the vod we gave
you right here
let me tell you this is the titan ii
this is the highest yield
intercontinental ballistic missile the
u.s has ever deployed okay if we go for
like the larger bombs so like iv mike is
10 megatons what if we hit it with for
example sorry not to interrupt like the
one you just said i don't i think it's
only been tested
the only news i think we ever used was
fat boy and was it a little boy and fat
man okay
yeah uh little boy and fat man yeah was
15 and 20 kiloton wow so let's let's say
somebody dropped a fat man on on
manhattan i mean yeah okay maybe then
you're like get inside because that
would only take out the financial
district but we're talking about modern
icbms so we have the bigger bombs we
have sar bama that's the largest ussr
bomb tested it's 50 megatons but that's
a gravity bomb bomb meaning a bomber
came in and dropped it they would never
get into u.s airspace it's not going to
happen right but let's say
the the titan ii warhead is nowhere near
the current level of technology that
we've actually developed or russia has
and they've actually got a 50 megaton
icbm okay you're not going anywhere
sorry
new york city doesn't exist anymore
stamford is getting hit what else do you
got like oh no
all gone new brunswick is gone all of
like the north uh northeast jersey coast
is just wiped out
sorry if the bomb is bigger than nine
megatons hey what do you um
what's your thought on
why
do you think they do you think that new
york was like hey this is a legitimate
threat we need to warn people with weird
advice and a goofy psa or do you think
it is some sort of distraction for
something like i mean there was a
meeting about this there was a
production they made it what do you
think they were thinking and why they
made it you know what honestly
i have no idea but i am wondering if
they're just sitting there you know and
dude's like spinning his pen he's like
we got 30k in the budget and we got to
use it this month it's like yeah we
could do a nuke psa yeah yeah that
sounds fun like oh i've been sleeping
with this actress who's been dying for
work like we'll get her in she's very
very charming yeah we did the fentanyl
testing one right
yeah
i mean really united air and box cutters
that's been done uh what else do we got
like what do you get like comments are
turned off on the video unfortunately
crazy well yeah because there's probably
a lot of questions right
like she says we don't know why yeah it
doesn't matter also but yeah like i want
to point out jamie mentioned this video
she's in like a ritzy loft i mean look
at that look at that couch this is what
i'm saying yeah she's worth millions and
millions yeah look at that size
spaciously
my apartment's so big i don't have room
for all my stuff i would say it could be
like 10 new york hipsters living in one
yeah i was going to say where are her 15
roommates but look at her flooring it
could be black friends the remake this
this this video was made for rich new
yorkers
yeah yeah you know who i'm talking to
everyone wink yeah when the newt comes
get inside right you know what i mean
get near the windows that have the
special drapes
i've been listening um lex friedman has
been talking i i don't know i have a lot
of respect for lex friedman you know if
you guys listen to him he's yeah he's
official intelligent scientist also does
jiu-jitsu uh in austin
he's actually over there in ukraine
right now
he's
i know it surprised me too wow i don't
i'm nothing i'm not saying he's better
or worse than any of us but he's been
concerned about nuclear i mean when i
start hearing other people talk about
nuclear war like i don't really think
it's on the table but i mean i guess
everything's on the table
yeah but what i'm hearing about is these
hypersonic weapons that it's like forget
icbms they take a while to get here
these things are these faster than sound
weaponry no no i think uh hypersonic are
faster i mean i'm sorry i'm sorry icbms
are faster i might have a hypersonic
icbm
uh hypersonic are uh
slower so icbms go into space
and they move really really really fast
the the issue i think with hypersonic i
could be totally wrong but i thought it
was detection is that it's um like more
uh conventional combat detection it's
easier and also we have merv weaponry
where like a nuclear weapon explodes in
the atmosphere and then creates like 70
new nuclear bombs
it just seems like there's so many that
we know of there's 12 warheads in one
icbms multiple independently targeting
re-entry
yeah so these singular blast zones are
like
just quelling our fear you know we'd
have like 12 blast zones when we when
when i pull up the titan ii and put it
over new york or like look at that what
you don't realize is that we've
developed something called the multiple
independently targeting re-entry vehicle
a merv it goes up into the stratosphere
and then breaks and drops eight to
twelve warheads which could deciding
pepper the whole eastern seaboard that's
actually what hunter biden causes um
i mean there's part of me
i'm not even being conspiratorial like
they're trying to cover it up but it's
at the best
wasteful where we have so many
real problems in this country with the
economy with mental health with drug
addiction with all the stuff we were
talking about right now that it's like
do we need to spend money on a psa for
like also maybe we're gonna get nuked
when we're probably not gonna get nuked
i wonder if they're watching the
wilkification of the military and
they're like oh we need to let people
know that this might actually happen
yeah they were sent putin may have
cancer which could lead to like mental
degradation and desperation where he's
just like i'm going out on a bang yeah
and like if he's on like prednisone and
it's messing with his thoughts and he's
like gonna become more likely to do
something stupid well because if he's
terminal i don't think he cares about
anybody else at that point right except
his legacy exactly right yeah very good
point yeah here's here i'll show you
this crazy this is crazy so um
if dc were to get hit with the surface
strike
we're flying we're up we're up near uh
charlestown over here so we're totally
fine we're fairly far away new york
actually gets hit
so take a look at this map where new
york gets hit with the radioactive
fallout from washington from washington
look at that it stretches all the way up
and we're talking
we're talking uh
this is this is
500 uh rem
34.6 so that's very much right in the
center sorry i don't think it gives us
okay here we go here we go
the fallout that would hit new york is
one rats per hour oh no i'm sorry no new
york it's whoa
new york gets hit heavy
10 rads per hour wow that's that's nuts
the fallout just
philadelphia's
yo baltimore is gone bel air you're all
in the max
the max radius for fallout that's
absolutely brutal delaware's getting
some sprinkles
yup jersey's jersey i mean this is a rat
as a radiation absorbed dose
so it's a unit of measure for radiation
yeah about how much that you can take
and everybody who plays fallout no rads
are bad yes and this is just from the
air sweeping it or is this
instantaneously it's the it's the air
current moving carrying the radio to
fall out so we're still safe because the
uh jet stream carries in the other
direction but yo
one strike on on you you have to know
like if it's russia or whoever or china
they know this if we can pull it up on
some silly little website yeah yeah if
you just taught it to me they know this
right right exactly you just taught two
comedians
okay on a podcast yeah they probably got
it
yeah the craziest thing about it
the radiation is intentional they could
make the bombs have limited or no
radiation or i don't about no but they
like there are there are nuclear bombs
that have no radioactive fallout after
the fact hey no big deal tim and feel
free to say no but can dave and i stay
here in the basement forever
because i'm very frightened
well
i mean
i gotta no one's gonna nuke texas i got
actually nobody's gonna nuke detroit
oh that's true i got a house there and
there there yeah that looks also you
know uh it's already been hit right
exactly i was gonna say they're gonna
look at them and be like no we already
got yeah like we did somebody did this
why would someone do this
no one like no one's going to nuke the
uh dayton funny bone with both me and
dave will be performing august august
august everyone they're uh china and or
russia's they're looking at a map of
cities and they're like which ones if we
hit like putin walks in he's like which
cities and then they're like pointing
and all the smoke rising is like what
about detroit and they're like that
wasn't us actually no no really really
well somebody did a very good job yeah
yeah yeah we did they did yesterday they
did that
we have to stop them
what about detroit they're like no they
just left it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you